tf1 20 heures avec dominique baudis salt
2 russes et américains font un pas de
plus dans la limitation de l'armement
nucléaire nouvelles obligations pour les
compagnies pétrolières
garantir pendant trois ans au moins 80%
de leurs approvisionnements
l'échec payant pour les petits clients
l'exemple du crédit du nord pourrait
être suivie par d'autres banques
les trois grands thèmes du congrès cfdt
de brest non au tout nucléaire la
semaine des 35 heures une meilleure
application de la loi sur l'interruption
de grossesse
bonsoir cette journée du 8 mai 1979
retiendra peut-être l'attention de ceux
qui plus tard étudieront l'histoire de
ce siècle
en effet aujourd'hui américains et
soviétiques viennent de tomber d'accord
pour limiter aux mêmes pour réduire
leurs armements nucléaires
moscou et washington après six longues
années de négociations sont enfin
parvenus à la conclusion d'un accord
salt 2 ces négociations sol s'éterniser
elle finissait par faire partie du
paysage diplomatique à tel point que
l'on oublie même parfois ceux qui se
cachent derrière ces initiales
il s'agit de limiter l'armement
nucléaire stratégique des deux grandes
superpuissance moscou et washington
avaient déjà conclu un premier accord
sol un
c'était en 1972 ce texte limite et les
armements nucléaires aujourd'hui avec le
nouvel accord salt 2 on va sensiblement
plus loin puisque moscou et washington
s'engagent à réduire leur potentiel
nucléaire
certains engins atomiques vont donc être
détruits ou dément clés pour comprendre
à quel point ces négociations étaient
difficiles il suffit de savoir que le
texte du nouvel accord salt 2 ne
comporte pas moins de cent pages et ce
document pourrait être signée le mois
prochain
messieurs clarté rêverait ginette se
retrouverait à mi-chemin de leurs deux
pays respectifs
la signature pourrait avoir lieu en
europe à stockholm sur ces accords salt
2 nous vous proposons un dossier en deux
volets avec gérard saint pol le contexte
les conséquences politiques de l'accord
mais tout de suite avec françois de
closets ses implications techniques et
militaires
l'accord salt 1 conclu entre messieurs
nixon et brejnev je lai en leur état les
arsenaux russie amérique
la russie avait plus de missiles mais
ceux des américains était plus
perfectionnés dans les années qui
suivirent russes et américains ne
pouvant plus développés le nombre de
leurs charmes s'appliquèrent à les
perfectionner les négociations d'un
accord salt 2 visant à arrêter cette
nouvelle course aux armements puis à les
limiter
furent entamée par gerald ford elles
aboutissent à un plafond comme un des
vecteurs stratégiques 2400 c'est plus
que non non les soviétiques moins que
non non les américains et ce plafond
devrait être abaissé à 2250 en 1981 met
des sous catégories sont prévues tout en
compte de la nature des armes et
notamment des têtes multiples points
délicats
le missile américain de croisière avions
automatique aéroportée qui a finalement
été inclus dans l'accord comme le
demandaient les soviétiques
en revanche le bombardier russe backside
reste en dehors mais son rayon d'action
ne devra pas être étendu la surveillance
de l'accord se fera depuis l'espace et
non par inspection terrestre sur les
lieux sur ces deux points le président
carter risque d'être critiquée au
congrès toutefois cet accord laisse
encore à chaque puissance la capacité de
détruire une bonne dizaine de fois son
adversaire
sur le plan politique maintenant
l'avenir des salt 2 c'est déjà ce hall 3
de même que l'avenir des soldes 1
c'était six ans plus tard les salt 2
tant il est vrai que l'on n'en finira
jamais de délimiter les limitation des
armements stratégiques depuis la
signature du premier accord à moscou le
26 mai 1972 avec richard nixon leonid
brejnev en est à son troisième président
américain pour ses négociations hyper
sophistiqué ici donc messieurs nixon et
brejnev signait un texte sur la
limitation des armements portant sur
cinq ans
ces documents étaient à peine entré en
vigueur le 3 octobre 72 que le 21
novembre suivant s'ouvrait le deuxième
cycle des négociations salt à genève
andreï gromyko le ministre les affaires
étrangères soviétique en était avec
enrique qui sinjar l'infatigable commis
voyageur négociateurs cela pendant deux
ans jusqu'à la publication le 24
novembre 1974 d'un communiqué commun à
vladivostok et un deuxième président
américain salt pour brejnev c'était
gerald ford
une occasion majeure c'était leur
première rencontre
ensuite ce sera un long cheminement
deux propositions américaines en rejet
soviétique jusqu'à ce qu'en mars 77
le nouveau secrétaire d'état américain
cyrus vance trouvent un accord cadre
avec les soviétiques pour discuter plus
complètement mais pour la suite
changement américains et soviétiques
voudrait inclure aux limitations
d'autres systèmes d'armement et moscou
surtout voudrais y associer la grande
bretagne et la france sur cette question
lors de son dernier voyage à moscou le
président giscard d'estaing a été très
ferme
la france juge aura salt 2 sur les
résultats elle n'est pas contre le
principe mais elle ne participera pas à
salt 3 parce que entre autres raisons la
force française de frappe perdre ex ont
l'effet de dissuasion
les habitants de l'état de californie va
faire l'expérience du rationnement
pétroliers en effet pour faire face à la
pénurie des mesures de restriction
interviendront dès demain dans cet état
de la côte ouest des états unis
en france la crise de l'énergie a
provoqué l'adoption d'une série de
mesures concernant justement les
approvisionnements cette nouvelle
réglementation concerne les compagnies
pétrolières vendant sur le marché
français deux points dans ces mesures
désormais ces compagnies sont libres de
vendre en france les quantités qu'ils
veulent mais en revanche pour être
autorisés à vendre sur le marché
français les compagnies devront tout
d'abord prouver qu'elles sont en mesure
de fournir du pétrole pendant une
période d'au moins trois ans une
réglementation qui vise donc à assurer
la sécurité des approvisionnements
daniel bigot
c'est depuis 1928 que la france
règlement très sévèrement le régime des
compagnies pétrolières agissant sur son
territoire pour pouvoir en effet
importer du pétrole
le raffiner le distribuer en france ces
pétroliers doivent demander une
autorisation au gouvernement
jusqu'à présent le but de la règle était
d'avantagé les compagnies françaises au
départ nettement plus faibles que leurs
concurrentes étrangères comme la shell
ou la bp des limitations de quantité
était alors imposé à ces firmes
étrangères
mais aujourd'hui et pour deux raisons
cette règle ne se justifie plus
premièrement les compagnie française elf
aquitaine et la cfp couvre maintenant la
moitié du marché français deuxièmement
leur taille leur permet d'être
compétitifs face à leurs concurrentes
étrangères tant au niveau de la
recherche de nouveaux gisements qu'au
niveau des installations de raffinage
en revanche aujourd'hui le nouvel
impératif économique pour la france
c'est la sécurité d'approvisionnement
c'est pourquoi de nouvelles règles ont
été définis et dorénavant ne seront
autorisés en france que les compagnies
qui assureront pendant trois ans au
moins 80% de leur approvisionnement sous
forme de contrats avec des fournisseurs
connu qu'il soit d'autres compagnies ou
plus simplement des pays producteurs
autre condition avoir les moyens de
stocker d'une façon permanente 6000
tonnes de pétrole c'est la réserve
obligatoire
en conclusion premièrement il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en liberté le régime des
compagnies pétrolières en france elle
demeure soumise à une règle qui
dorénavant met l'accent sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
deuxièmement il ne s'agit pas de
remettre non plus en liberté les prix du
carburant du fioul
d'une part les conditions de prix
d'achat du pétrole pour ces compagnies
restent les mêmes d'autre part il n'est
toujours pas question de supprimer la
réglementation des prix à la pompe
la fixation des prix par le gouvernement
demeure pour le consommateur un
garde-fou hausses abusives
faudra-t-il un jour prochain payer pour
pouvoir effectuer une opération bancaire
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser à
la suite de l'initiative que vient de
prendre le crédit d'une
un établissement privé depuis un mois en
effet cette banque fait payer à ses
clients un franc cinquante par
opérations de débit cela signifie que
pour le paiement d'un chèque ou pour un
versement forfaitaire à l'edf aux ptt la
banque taxes le client d'un franc
cinquante à chaque fois le crédit du
nord a prévu quelques exceptions trois
opérations gratuites par trimestre et
plus le compte en banque du client est
important plus il aura droit à des
opérations gratuites c'est donc une
formule qui pénalise les clients les
plus modestes
devant une telle initiative de questions
se posent comment le crédit du nord
justifie t-il cette taxation et d'autre
part ces mesures pourrait elle s'étendre
un jour à d'autres établissements
bancaires à laver l'air la loi stipule
que le nouveau chèques barrés non
endossables et gratuit le crédit du nord
a esquivé la loi en décidant de faire
payer un franc cinquante noms l'échec
eux mêmes mais les écritures les
opérations de banque
il y a une écriture pour chaque virement
pour chaque retrait d'espèces et pour
chaque chèque bien sûr en pratique seuls
seront axés les clients aux comptes en
banque maigre qui établissent beaucoup
de chèques pour régler le moindre achat
et encore la mesure ne sera appliquée ni
aux nouveaux clients ni aux moins de 25
ans ni à ceux qui en plus de leurs
comptes chèques possèdent un compte sur
livret un plan d'épargné etc
qu'importe la brèche est ouverte une
brèche qui comble les voeux de la
profession bancaire
après avoir attiré le petit client en
multipliant les succursales les banques
aurait-elle décidé de le rançonner leur
explication la voici en dix ans le
nombre d'échecs a été multipliée par six
dépassant le milliard et demi par an le
chèque représente plus de la moitié des
opérations des banques auxquelles ils
coûtent entre 3 et 5 francs chacun 3 à 5
30 papier de frais d'impression
d'écritures comptables de frais de
présentation chambre de compensation et
sert à réduire les frais de gestion
les banques font le maximum mais cela
reste insuffisant alors reste deux
solutions faire payer davantage aux
emprunteurs ou taxer les déposants comme
les emprunteurs paye déjà le crédit très
cher et que les déposants eux ne payent
rien la seconde solution paraît
l'emporter grands arguments des banques
c'est ce qui se passe à l'étranger en
italie en paye 170 lire 0,185 par chèque
en grande bretagne 9 à 10 pence en
0 1 franc par opération en allemagne
certaines banques taxe les opérations
d'autres l'échec en belgique il existe
une taxe sur les petits contes et aux
états unis
des formules de frais fixes mensuels la
tendance est donc aux chèques payant
bien qu'au ministère des finances on
affirme qu'il n'est pas question
actuellement de modifier la loi
à terme il y aura une grande
bénéficiaire de la carte de crédit avec
elle
quel que soit le nombre de règlements il
n'y aura jamais qu'une seule écriture qu
une seule opération bancaire par mois
journée de commémoration aujourd'hui
pour ce 34e anniversaire du 8 mai 1945
ce jour-là l'allemagne nazie s'incliner
devant les forces alliées des cérémonies
ont été organisées dans les villes de
france
monsieur chirac le maire de paris a
déposé une gerbe à l'arc de triomphe
et puis les anciens de rhin et danube se
sont également recueillis sur le tombeau
du soldat inconnu
coïncidence des dates le 8 mai marque
également le 550e anniversaire de la
libération d'orléans par jeanne d'arc à
cette occasion le président de la
république a présidé les cérémonies
d'orléans jacques hébert a suivi pour
nous la célébration de cet anniversaire
de la victoire de jeanne d'arc
jeanne d'arc ne faisait pas de politique
politicienne nous devons cet audacieux
commentaires sur l'appui celle qui
délivra il y a cinq cent cinquante ans
aujourd'hui
la ville d'orléans et bien nous le
devons à l'un de nos confrères orléanais
et bien pour valéry giscard d'estaing
aujourd'hui il n'était pas question non
plus de politique politicienne loin ce
genre de soucis aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la journée était consacrée
essentiellement à la tradition et à la
fête d'une heure sous la chaleur
printanière enfin retrouvé le président
de la république traversera à pied la
ville d'orléans sur son passage
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes l'accueil est bon enfant
valéry giscard d'estaing parcourera 5 km
au pas lent de la marche consulaire mais
le chef de l'état ne sera pas le seul à
traverser la ville dans le cortège
traditionnel se retrouvaient pêle-mêle
la jeune lycéenne de 17 ans qui
incarnait cette année le personnage de
jeanne d'arc
on y trouvait également les membres du
clergé avec le président des évêques
français monseigneur etchegaray
et puis toujours pêle-mêle la
magistrature
les enfants des écoles les anciens
combattants les majorettes
le conseil municipal d'orléans les clubs
sportifs locaux et même quelques
ambassadeurs de pays étrangers
le défilé se terminer il ya un peu plus
de deux heures par un défilé militaire
mais au cours de son allocution de ce
matin à la mairie d'orléans
après l'office dans la cathédrale sainte
croix le chef de l'état a voulu lier
cette 550e commémoration de la
libération d'orléans à l'europe l'europe
a dit valéry giscard d'estaing et
pacifique
tous les français y sont attachés il
faut que la france devait il ajouter
donne dans cette europe
l'image d'un pays uni et tournée vers
l'avenir car l'unité nationale conclura
le chef de l'état doit demeurer l'unique
moteur de notre grandeur et de notre
influence cette unité mystérieuse que
zain a créé autour d'elle pendant
quelques mois a suffi à sauver le
royaume de france
cette unité retrouvée en 1940 sous un
chef historique nous conduisent it aux
vitraux combat victorieux de 1945 je
souhaite que l'unité nationale maintenu
et préserver contre toutes les divisions
conduisent la france dans la voie de la
grandeur et de la paix et comme jeanne
avait su le faire hausse les esprits
vers l'espérance des temps meilleurs
en france tout joueur réunion depuis ce
matin à brest du congrès de la cfdt le
secrétaire général de la confédération
monsieur edmond maire a fait une longue
déclaration à la tribune
il a proposé d' entre autres aux
congressistes trois objectifs lutter
dans les entreprises et dans les
communes pour une meilleure application
de la loi sur l'interruption de
grossesse
d'autre part s'opposer à ce qu'ils
appellent le tout nucléaire
enfin poursuivre et développer les
actions en faveur de la semaine de 35
heures françois bossuyt pour nous
congrès la cfdt pour progresser dans la
réponse ouvrière à la crise rien ne peut
remplacer cette pratique démocratique
d'élaboration de revendications
concrètes porteuse d'un changement du
type de production et de consommation
d'un changement de la division sociale
du travail de l'organisation du travail
de l'outil de travail
un changement du mode de vie et du type
de développement
notre ambition vise à réduire dès
aujourd'hui la hiérarchie des salaires
les revenus et des pouvoirs à élargir
les espaces de liberté dans l'entreprise
et la société à imposer d'autres
éléments de réorganisation du travail et
de restructuration industrielle une
autre politique de l'emploi que celles
qui découlent de la logique impitoyable
de restructuration d intérêt capital
pour avancer concrètement sur le terrain
dans une mousse telle direction nous
devons nous interroger sur la fonction
du syndicat sur son efficacité
c'est tout le sens
de l'accent mis par la confédération
depuis un an sur la négociation
une explication pour la politique
d'action d'acer des prix en appelle à
l'unité lancé à la cgt un avertissement
pour le gouvernement et pour le patronat
le bilan des négociations nationales est
faible voilà l'avertissement est aussi
une confirmation
l'état-major de la cfdt va maintenir sa
ligne d'action pour cette première
journée
le discours programme elmer a été
fraîchement accueillie mais sévèrement
critiqué un recentrage oui mais un
recentrage à gauche a réclamé un délégué
saluée par un tonnerre d'avertissement
voilà qui donne le ton de l'opposition m
il n'y a pas que l'opposition au sein de
ce congrès il y a ceux qui estiment que
la nouvelle stratégie la seule voie
possible pour le syndicalisme en 1979
en réalité pour savoir si la nouvelle
stratégie de la cfdt sera approuvée
outre une année eh bien il va falloir
attendre le vote des congressistes
prévue pour jeudi soir dans l'immédiat
ce n'est ni un échec ni succès pour
cette nouvelle stratégie pour ont résumé
d'une phrase jamais la cfdt ne s'est
autant chercher pour ce mois de mai 1970
françois gourd tf
et puis demain ce sera l'ouverture du
23ème congrès du parti communiste à
saint-ouen d'entrée de jeu le secrétaire
général monsieur marché présentera un
rapport devant les congressistes
rappelons que les congrès du parti
communiste ont lieu tous les trois ans
le dernier le 22e par conséquent avait
lieu en 1976 il était placé sous le
signe de l'ouverture à l'intérieur des
frontières
ouverture en direction des autres partis
de gauche à l'extérieur ouverture en
direction des autres partis communistes
européens depuis trois ans beaucoup de
choses se sont passées il ya eu
notamment la crise de l'union de la
gauche
et puis les élections de mars 78 à la
veille de ce congrès dont nous
reparlerons bien sûr dans les jours qui
viennent
françois lambert nous explique le
fonctionnement du parti communiste le
parti communiste français revendique 700
mille adhérents dont 250 mille femmes la
classe ouvrière représentent 51 % de ses
effectifs
les employés 28 % les techniciens 4,4
pour cent
les intellectuels enseignants écrivains
professions libérales 13,5 pour cent
il compte également dans ses rangs dix
sept mille exploitants agricoles et 20
mille artisans et commerçants le parti
fonctionne selon une structure
pyramidale de la cellule au comité
central
il existe deux types de cellules les
cellules d'entreprise ou les militants
ce groupe là où ils travaillent et les
cellules locales ou rural réunissant les
communistes sur leur lieu de résidence
le parti compte vingt-huit mille
cellules dont 10000 d'entreprises qui
sont regroupés en section il y a environ
3000 section rassemblant donc les
cellules de quartier et d'entreprises
cellules et section d'un même
département constitue une fédération il
en existe au total 98 dans certains
départements il peut y en avoir deux
c'est le cas du finistère et de la
meurthe et moselle l'ensemble des
fédérations constitue donc le parti
communiste dont le congrès réunit tous
les trois ans et l'organisme s'ouvre il
élit le comité central qui lui même est
lié un bureau politique et un
secrétariat organe exécutif du parti le
parti communiste compte vingt-huit mille
élus 86 députés 22 sénateurs 15 cents
maires 27 1412 conseillers municipaux et
480 conseillers généraux le parti
communiste français dispose d'une presse
au premier rang de laquelle figurent
l'humanité qui tirent quotidiennement à
300000 exemplaires l'humanité dimanche
diffusé par les militants à un tirage de
500 mille exemplaires la presse
communiste possède également des
quotidiens régionaux des hebdomadaires
comme france nouvelles et des revues
parmi lesquels on peut citer la nouvelle
critique et les cahiers du communisme
les communistes organise chaque année en
septembre
l'une des manifestations populaires les
plus importantes du pays
la fête de l'humanité l'organisation le
fonctionnement la vie interne du parti
sont régies par le centralisme
démocratique qui se caractérise par les
principes suivants la discussion de tous
les problèmes est libre à tous les
échelons une fois les décisions prises à
la majorité
elles sont appliquées par tous
l'organisation et l'activité de
fractions sont interdites les organismes
dirigeants des différents échelons sont
élus démocratiquement par les assemblées
de cellules les conférence de section de
fédérations et des congrès
enfin les décisions des organismes
supérieurs sont obligatoires pour les
organismes inférieur ce principe de base
du fonctionnement du parti a été on s'en
souvient contesté par un certain nombre
de militants considérant que le
centralisme a pris le pas sur la
démocratie
si vous portez un week-end et même si
vous rentrez tard le dimanche 10 juin le
jour des élections européennes
vous pourrez tout de même accomplir
votre devoir civique en effet on votera
pour la première fois jusqu'à 22 heures
dans toute la france et maintenant votre
compagnie jean claude narcy la suite de
l'actualité bien grande bretagne
l'incendié d'un grand magasin de vins
chester a fait cet après midi plus de 10
morts et 62 blessés
plus de cent personnes se trouvaient
dans le restaurant du deuxième étage de
ce grand magasin lorsque le feu s'est
déclaré
imaginez la panique qui s'ensuivit les
pompiers ne centaine environ les
pompiers de la ville sont intervenus
très vite pour circonscrire le sinistre
le bilan est donc provisoire de dix
morts et de 60 personnes qui se trouvent
ce soir à l'hôpital première réunion
aujourd'hui du nouveau cabinet
britannique à londres
les 22 membres du gouvernement qui
entourait le premier ministre cette
chère il n'y avait pas d'agenda fixait
mais non c'est qu'il a été question du
budget du prochain discours de la reine
qui serait fixé dit on au 15 mai
prochain les nouveaux ministres ont
également évoqué la situation en irlande
du nord
jérémy sort paix est revenue aujourd'hui
devant ses juges l'ancien chef du parti
libéral britannique qui vient de perdre
le siège de député qu'il occupait depuis
20 ans est accusé de complicité et
d'incitation meurtre de l'ancien
mannequin masculin
norman scott qui prétend lui avoir eu
des relations homosexuelles avec
l'ancien député en iran la chasse aux
membres du groupe extrémiste islamique
forgan responsable de l'assassinât
l'ayatollah motahari s'intensifie et
l'épuration reprend de plus belle
vingt-et-une personnes ont été fusillées
ce matin à téhéran
c'est la plus importante exécutions
collectives depuis la révolution les 21
exécuté de ce matin sont des anciens
ministres des militaires et des
policiers à fès au maroc la conférence
islamique s'est ouvert cet après midi
sans la délégation égyptienne comme le
souhaitait plusieurs des pays
participants
et c'est le roi hassan 2 qui annoncent
et qui a prononcé un discours lors de la
séance inaugurale le but essentiel je
vous le rappel de l'organisation
islamique et deux vrais pour la
renaissance du monde musulman la
coopération dans tous les domaines entre
les états membres le soutien de la cause
palestinienne et la libération de
jérusalem au liban sud les forces
aériennes israéliennes ont bombardé
cette après midi des concentrations de
fedayins à la pointe nord-est de la
frontière israélo-libanaise dispositif
spécial san salvador au quai d'orsay
jour et nuit le cabinet du ministre des
affaires étrangères est sur le pied de
guerre est en contact avec l'amérique
centrale
sur place c'est l'ambassadeur de france
est toujours retenu en otage avec
plusieurs de ses collaborateurs depuis
cinq jours maintenant je vous le
rappelle et en ce qui concerne les trois
otages l'ambassade du costa rica bien
ils n'ont pas été relâchés comme cela
avait été dit dans la journée mais ce
sont bien enfui de l'ambassade où il
était retenu prisonnier et puis enfin le
président panaméen julio en visite
officielle à paris actuellement joue le
rôle de médiateur pour favoriser un
dénouement que l'on veut te re à cette
affaire la direction l'usiné
sidérurgique seul maire de fos-sur-mer a
suspendu la décision annoncée ce matin
de mettre en chômage technique tout le
personnel elle motive sa décision par le
constat que les opérations de remise en
marge du haut fourneau numéro 2 se
déroule normalement
attention si vous prenez l'avion jeudi
en raison de la grève des personnels au
sol d'air france la compagnie nationale
va modifier le programme de ces vols si
vous voyagez le 10 mai prochain donc je
dis téléphoner avant au centre de
réservation de la région de votre
domicile
le déficit de la sncf pour soixante dix
huit se monte à 1 million à du moins
1100 19 millions bardon de francs pour
monsieur burgart le secrétaire général
de sncf 79 devrait être une année sans
déficit
compte tenu du contrat d'entreprise
signés cette année avec l'état
géorgiques ou démissionne de ses
fonctions de secrétaire général du
cidunati qu'il assurait depuis dix ans
motif invoqué bien gérard nicoud veut
mettre de l'ordre dans ses propres
affaires
il sera remplacé par un triumvirat
chargé de diriger le mouvement jusqu'au
congrès extraordinaire du 11 juin
prochain
l'espagnol bernardo lopez alphonse elle
a remporté en solitaire la 14e étape de
la vuelta cycliste le sang en 10 175 km
le néerlandais soutenait elle conserve
la première place au classement général
alphonse l auteur d'une échappée de 135
km s'est imposé donc devant ajoute m
à 5 minutes 21 secondes enfin vous allez
voir à présent des images du fantastique
exploit réalisé par l'américain reynaldo
nehemia il a battu hier le record du
monde du 110 m haies en 13 secondes
juste vous allez le voir sur votre écran
il est deuxième il est du moins la
deuxième ligne à gauche et sachez que
s'il avait couru à montréal et bien leur
hébétude hydrure de 3 m
bravo sur l'ensemble de la france le
thermomètre continue de monter les
hausses des températures était
particulièrement sensible aujourd'hui
dans le centre le nord-est et le
centre-est et puis demain demain sur la
majeure partie du pays le temps sera
généralement chaud et ensoleillé
on prévoit toutefois quelques passages
nuageux sur la moitié sud de la france
ils seront accompagnés d'averses parfois
orageuses quelques nuages également sur
les régions situées au nord de la seine
une exposition ouvre ses portes
aujourd'hui à paris 49 rue des mathurins
et les visiteurs pourront y découvrir
une galerie de une galerie de portraits
qui serait tout à la fois une galerie de
glace déformante plus d'une centaines de
visages célèbres traités par mulatier
morchoisne eric or il nous propose ces
grandes gueules dont ils ont d'ailleurs
fait un album publié sous ce titre aux
éditions du pont neuf comme dans la
meilleure tradition de la caricature ces
trois dessinateurs parviennent à
retrouver la réalité à travers
l'outrance tous les grands de ce monde
du monde de la politique ou du monde du
spectacle ont été transformés déformer
puis retrouvée sous les crayons de ces
trois caricaturiste c3 caricaturiste que
découvrait à jour rené goscinny le père
d'astérix
c'était à l'époque trois jeunes garçons
âgés de 12 ans il veut les voir goscinny
avec leurs premiers dessins sous le bras
dans ces grandes gueules on trouve
beaucoup de vérité on ne trouve pas de
méchanceté il faut même sans doute
éprouvé une secrète tendresse pour son
sujet si l'on veut à ce point restituer
ce qui transparaît de sa personnalité
c'est à 23h10 que d'annuelles du goût
vous présentera la dernière édition de
tf1 actualité merci de votre attention
passer une bonne soirée